تم اختيار فيلم اغنيه الغراب المخرج
السعودي محمد السلمان لتمثيل السعوديه في
فئه افضل فيلم دولي ضمن جوائز الاوسكار
لعام 20 23 صباح العربيه التقى مخرج
الفيلم محمد سلمان
من هيئه الافلام تبع صندوق
كتبت الفكره في 2019 وطورتها في 2020
وصورناها في العام الماضي 21 وهذه السنه
ان شاء الله راح يشارك فيه مهرجان الافلام
السعوديه
فالمغنيه الغراب هو عباره عن قصه
لشخصيه اسمها ناصر بسيطه يعني
تدخل في حياتها فتاه غامضه فيحاول الوصول
لها عن طريق كتابه اغنيه
فيلم من بطوله عاصم العواد شخصيه ناصر
الشخصيه الرئيسيه بمشاركه
ابراهيم الخير الله شخصيه ابو صقر وعبد
الله الجفال شخصيه ابو ياسر
احداث الفيلم تصير في الرياض تعال في عام
2002 فتره ومثيره للاهتمام بالنسبه لي
فيها تيارات فكريه مختلفه ومشهد ثقافي لا
لمسته الخاصه
فالشخصيه يعني
تاخذ رحله
غير عاديه في هذه الاجواء
تراب
عليه حبيت اني
اسوي الحاجه اللي انا حاببها
اللي انا حاب اجربها في هذا الفيلم
ثم نشوف كيف الجمهور او المهرجانات تتفاعل
معه خلينا نقول من ناحيه السر وطريقه
السرد كنت صادق فيها
وااخذ هذه التجربه مع المشاهدين يعني انا
ان شاء الله بعد عرض الفيلم راح همم اكتشف
عن طريق انطباعات الناس كيف فعل مع هذا
[تصفيق]
في هذا الفيلم واجهنا عده تحديات وصعوبات
وكل تجربه لها تحديات خاصه لكن هذا الفيلم
كان طموح اييي
وعملناه بشكل نوعا ما كان مستقل زين امم
وفي وقت مره قصير لكن كان معانا فريق
الصراحه رائع جدا
سواء على مستوى الممثلين همم
المؤدين والمنتجين والقسم التصوير وقسم
الديكور كان ناس
وكانوا قد التحدي والحمد لله يعني قدرنا
نخلص الفيلم بالشكل اللي احنا راضيين عنك
الشاي خمر المؤمن بس يضل الحرام لذيذ
من احد الاشياء اللي انا مره مبسوط فيها
بهذا المشروع هو ااه العمل مع عاصم
العواده الشخصيه الرئيسيه همم اسم جديد
لكن كان على مستوى احترافيه عاليه جدا
كان معي طوال الوقت لما اخترناه كان بيحضر
اختبارات الاداء الاداءات الشخصيات الاخرى
فكان همم متشرب
المشاعر المفروض وهو يؤديها فانكس هذا
كثير في ايام التصوير همم باتمنى همم من
بعد هذا الفيلم يعني مستقبل رائع جدا ان
شاء الله الفيلم راح يتم توزيعها بعد
مهرجان البحر الاحمر سواء في صلاه السينما
او في منصات العامه شلون اسوي عمليه ممكن
يلا تشيز
الفيلم تم اختياره هذه السنه اللي يمثل
المملكه في مسابقه الاوسكار وهذا مره يعني
يسعدنا الصراحه يتم تفاعل مع هذا في ال في
السوشيال ميديا والاعلامي الى اخره لكن
الفيلم هو احد ثمرات جهود عديده همم
يعني الصعود بهذا القطاع طيب وعلى اولهم
هيئه الافلام همم فان شاء الله نكون يعني
جديرين بهذه الثقه
[موسيقى]
اصلا شو الفرق حيل واقع
كل واحد بالاخير تجربه حقيقيه في دماغك
زي التيس